congratulations laura i think i heard
imessages coming in for people
congratulations that was going on it's
uh
so great to have everyone here
celebrating an amazing year for games
all right we are streaming on every
platform tonight
including twitch where we have drops for
among us and fortnite who both have
world premieres
coming up later in the show and
throughout the night we will also be
interactive on twitch you can predict
who you think
will win using a twitch extension first
up best ongoing game so go and vote now
lock in your predictions all right well
even with everything going on it's been
one of those special years that sees the
launch
of new next-gen consoles and with that
brings a whole new generation
of games tonight we are honored to have
one
team a new team of veterans reveal the
very first details about their ambitious
and exciting new project
right here at the game awards enjoy
pretty much since the day i started
there's been a really clear
player fantasy i think the thing that
makes it different from a lot of
first-person games is
it's not just about shooting eco sci-fi
is a term that we use future fiction
but from an ecological focus there's
been this ecological disaster these
corporations came in
and they developed new technology and on
the surface everything's
everything's pretty great we're still
early in development but we're really
excited with where things are going we
wanted to share a cinematic piece that
helps set the tone
for our world
i remember when everything changed
the floods the storms
the fires people dying in the streets
the corporations gave us solutions
[Music]
a better world
and we welcome them into our lives
but the laws of nature aren't meant
to be broken we need to know what
they're hiding
[Music]
world
[Music]
[Music]
so
did you find the answers you were
looking for
agent dark not yet
this is just the beginning
you